Oftentimes you will want to gather input from a user and you'll give the user
instructions such as, please enter a value less than 100. The user then may do
something wrong, as users sometimes do. So, here we have someone disregarding
the instruction and now what do you do? often times what you do is you simply,
politely ask again and the user might still get it wrong not understanding that
less than 100 means less than 100. So, you'd ask again. And now finally, the
user gets it right. This is a very common situation, and it turns out to be
surprisingly difficult to program. Here are two possible solutions to this, the
blue one and the black one. And, I'd like you to look at both of them and see
which one would work. Take your time, and tell me, is the blue one the right
one? The black one, do both work? Or does neither of them work?